famille d'henri d'orléans recueilli dans
la chapelle royale saint louis une
cérémonie religieuse suivie par de
nombreuses personnalités
c'est le fils du comte de paris qui
accueille le prince albert de monaco
stéphane bern est également présent il a
bien connu le comte de paris
s'il n'avait pas été prince s'il n'avait
pas été mis dans cette position un peu
difficile d'être un roi sans royaume en
quelque sorte parce que vous êtes le
chef d'une maison royale qui n'existe
plus la france à un autre régime depuis
un certain nombre d'années
mais au fond c'était il aurait été un
artiste
vous savez d'abord les orléans est
hérité d'un don artistique tous
absolument tous et lui s'étaient
l'aquarelle le 21 janvier dernier henri
d'orléans s'éteint à l'âge de 85 ans ce
matin là il devait participer à une
cérémonie en hommage à louis saez il
allait régulièrement tous les ans le 21
janvier à la paroisse des rois de france
s'ingère dans le look zéro en face du
louvre il s'apprêtait à y aller tout
d'un coup il s'est senti mal il s'est
allongé et il est mort c'est quelque
chose à l'heure même où louis saez
mouret 226 ans plus tard il meurt lui
même stéphane bern était un proche de
cette famille royale qu'il fréquentait
depuis très longtemps on peut pas
l'oublier vous savez je ne renie pas ce
que j'ai été quand j'étais jeune j'avais
17 ans 18 ans 20 ans je j'ai dix-sept
familles j'écrivais pour eux je faisais
je n'oublie pas voilà il faut avoir un
peu de mémoire un peu de loyauté et
beaucoup de fidélité dans nos vies à
dreux la chapelle royale est une
nécropole de la famille d'orléans voulue
par le roi louis-philippe pour lui et
ses descendants
le comte de paris repose désormais lui
aussi